we have been remembering the complex and
dynamic life of our mother and story she
was every woman perhaps this is why
everyone felt they knew her
naomi judd's family and peers celebrate
her life as a country star wife and
mother
naomi was someone who never hesitated
never hesitated to show kindness or
compassion to others
ashley and wynonna judd and naomi's
husband larry strickland share emotional
tributes during naomi judd a river of
time celebration
our circumstances do not have the power
to name our identity
because as my mother taught me we are
spiritual beings having a human
experience
ashley breaks down as she praises her
mother's impact on the music genre she
called home
she cultivated those preternatural
mother-daughter harmonies and eventual
stardom
and the result is that we are here
tonight remembering an icon and a legend
who left country music better than she
found it
wynonna honors her mother by performing
a river of time
one of the many duets she and naomi sang
as the judge
surrounded by ashley and wynonna naomi's
husband reflects on his wife of 32 years
naomi
never met a stranger
much to my displeasure she would start a
conversation
with anyone that made eye contact with
it
among the many star-studded tributes
oprah winfrey praises naomi's musical
legacy
we were all so moved by her music in
part because of how she viewed her
rooted connection to all of us and
whenever we hear her voice we will be
forever reminded of the purity of her
heart the memorial follows ashley's
heartbreaking appearance on good morning
america ashley went outside to bring in
a comforting person who had arrived when
she came back i went upstairs to let her
know that the friend was there and i
discovered her
i have both grief and trauma
from
from discovering her
she opened up about naomi's death and
her mother's struggle with depression
my mother knew
that she was seen and she was hurt and
her anguish
and that
that she
she
she was walked home when we're talking
about mental illness it's very important
and
to be clear and to make the distinction
between our loved one and the disease
it's very real
and it's an it is it is enough to
it it lies
it's
savage in one of et's first interviews
with ashley judd the actress opened up
about the special connection she feels
with her family
sometimes i see myself
as
the embodiment
of mom and winona
because i have a lot of mom's wandering
spirit
and i have a lot of one owner's love for
life
you